hey reject nation Greg Alba here hey
reject nation Greg outta here
dodge on one of our reward tiers on
patreon whatever video you request we
must definitely do that and we missed
one for February that was Andrew Hayes
he was in a collab with us
but he also pledged high enough to get
that video request he asked that we do a
reaction to the follow-up to that other
sketch he did how to survive the
snowpocalypse now we they got how to
survive this spring apocalypse alright
so many pocalypse is let's see it
[Music]
rich we need to do something but is that
right no no no Rick don't you remember
just kidding we're not really it's just
me Ginny sharp and Louie Mac oh and with
my show
almost got canceled luckily we're still
here so we got to do another episode of
this magnificent show so so our host
Rick manly sure does have survived its
no-pocalypse oh my god no way
so after you see Brad he showed him
steps on how to survive this snowy well
of course he did after all failed
attempts it finally came to the
realization that maybe we should wait
till spring so which brings here today
ouch don't you back already
no there's still pop looks
[Music]
wife left me because of this [ __ ]
snow populist now I just
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
whitewalls ER twice in the script and
I'm seriously ticked off and I'm gonna
show you a house fire spreading
pocalypse
[Music]
effexor those
imagine there's like digital shorts that
like Andy Samberg laser go outside and
make sure all the snow
[Music]
[Music]
you sure yeah take it off
I don't even want to see okay there's my
favorite Halloween costume well three we
gotta eat something because if we want
its abundance regardless gotta eat food
selfie luckily nature has funded all the
food we need what are you doing flower
[Music]
[Music]
I
look how these credits relating to time
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
I survived our host Rick Manley showed
us how to survive the snow who is that I
love those kind of friends
middle of a take friends who say I
[ __ ] hate you Andrew
I know last time we checked out the
hottest around snowpocalypse I brought
this up I'm gonna bring it up again did
you hook up with Jamie it or not did you
tap that digit tap Jamie's ass comment
and tell me if you tapped Jaime's ass
otherwise what's the point of us filming
these what's the point if it's not
helping you tap Jaime's ass on a serious
note because there's always room to be
serious yes oh we weren't being serious
this whole time what I prefer this one
over the snowpocalypse one because the
snowpocalypse one felt like they were
attempting to put together like a really
good quality youtube sketch and it was
kind of funny in the way it was really
just like a home video yeah this what I
felt like oh they're actually like
self-awareness like a crazy sort of meta
surreal yeah especially with Andrew
because I liked whenever he was breaking
out a character like it just shows up
he's just Andrew my name's not Rick what
do you want yeah yeah well yeah just
like coming in and out of character like
looking at the air not wanting to do
this it seemed like they were much more
aware of the kind of video that the
snowpocalypse came out to be there are
stuff I'm like well no it actually feels
like intentional a lot of it now yeah
yeah what I'm so you know it gives them
a chance to try out some nifty things
like that that green screen bit was
actually kind of nifty in a low fight
yeah
and embracing it like that oddly makes
it sort of work you know yeah man is
there a third one Andrew as water
next to shoot oh well at the Walmart for
the Walmart pocalypse unless one of you
like we're gonna promote you Walmart
take a look at how to survive the
snowpocalypse apocalypse this is what
Shay guys all marketing in your ad
Department this is the kind of hype you
oh man but on a lighter note did you
hook up with Jamie did you hook up with
Jamie it looked like that one guy might
have been hooking up with Jamie skinny
arms guy maybe Brad
I'll talk to Jamie for it maybe jamie
has has her own life outside of these
videos I don't think so she writes
directs and edits videos well hats off
to you that's off to you Jamie for
embracing the absurdity of this and the
loaf I of it yeah what's the third one
gonna be how like what's the tone of the
next one gonna be is it gonna be like
that much more crazy it's gonna be like
really obtuse and hard to understand
think it should be like really great
high quality that's not funny at all
yeah really yeah oddly affecting like a
Fincher movie I think all right guys
well thanks Andrew Hayes outro that
you